i was i came very late to the project it
was written you know seven peterland has
been adapted uh nick's cow's book and
gary webb's dark alliance and it went
into turn around it was developed at
universal 107. and then renner got
involved uh he was i think really the
force that was able to sort of unshelve
it was he always attached to it or with
that no he wasn't but it's you know in
07 i think because the journalism movies
weren't doing well in the box office as
it always happens that's how hollywood
works they wait for the genre to sort of
become the thing again like maybe like
homeland or something
and uh
it
renner attached himself to the project
as a producer because he started a
company and you know he's able sort of
his name was able to get a green lit and
then i came on board i had worked with
jeremy on two projects so we had a
history um
i remembered the story but i didn't
i i wasn't really fully aware of the
amount of discrediting that went on and
so the
the grinder that this man went through
so i just really saw that as you know
real real injustice and also shocking of
the media actually taking down
their own and um
you know gary was at war with his bliss
and i i thought it was a really worthy
story to tell rosemarie did you know the
story beforehand you know i didn't and
that was part of the intrigue for me was
i i couldn't believe i didn't know it
that was and it wasn't like i was under
a rock you know i think i just graduated
college and and i uh was really thrilled
that the opportunity to to play a real
life person and someone i would have
access to and i know after meeting with
sue and spending time with her it was
really important to the family that gary
b vindicated actually you jumped in
because i did want to know how how
did you spend time with her and how you
got to learn i did she was really uh
generous and available to us wouldn't
you say yeah i mean she shared home
movies um i i flew up to where she lives
and i spent the day with her and you
know i didn't want to be like a
journalist to her because this is her
life and you know there are kids and
they had to live in the aftermath of the
postscript
but she was very uh very generous and
and even though they divorced she was
still
a big fan of his i mean i spoke with sue
very early on and i found that to be
the best thing for me to understand gary
as a man so it was all about just
getting to know what he was like at home
and as a guy
you know more of the story was from all
the materials and everything like that
and also revisiting all the articles
that were written about it you know the
post and the the l.a times and all that
and new york times but sue was really
helpful because it helped me understand
gary more as a real guy and i think a
filmmaker has to at least i like to sort
of play the method director a little bit
and
really
feel like i can be this guy and be in
his shoes and understand that
that dogged passion that he had for his
um for his family but of course for his
for
getting the truth out in his group and
then what about um
jeremy renner as a uh method actor is
that part of the part of the part of the
process
jeremy um
you know he he's such an instinctual
actor you know he's so um
so
being so honest and always i just
remember you know when we worked
together i was like i have to
work with this man again and he's you
know
gonna be a star or you know um and his
sort of startup i guess happened a
little later as far as being an action
hero or whatever but um
at the heart he's like got a great sort
of complexity and darkness
um maybe that's why it took a little
longer i mean he started with jeffrey
dahmer you know he played the dahmer
character in the famous indy
that goes way back
so he always brings a little of that to
whatever he does um
you know i always reference the scene on
the uh driveway
when when he's saying goodbye to you
guys and that jeremy was so sort of
i mean he didn't have to say anything
you just knew where he was emotionally
the thing that i think
would be the biggest challenge and it's
interesting that this has been around
you say since 2007 is that dude
oh seven yeah i think that's maybe when
it started but by the time it was
shelved i go away because because the
balance of
what he did
well or not so well as a journalist and
what
fellow journalists did to him
seem like the two sides of the story
where did he
tell the truth where was he sloppy not
in telling the truth not that he didn't
tell the truth but he was sloppy in his
journalistic approach
and the balance
seems to
come down more heavily in the film on
journalism eight one of its own yeah i
mean he
look he connected a lot of dots i
believe the story was printed too early
you know and
it was a three-part series web one gary
wanted a five-part six-part series and
they edited it way way down and at that
point he went up to his you know uh he
sent the story in and then
remember the scene it's like don't mess
it up she's like i got it i mean they
brought it down and they packaged it
properly they made it
very sensational and they put the crack
pipe well the crack pipe on the cia logo
is just the epitome of like
of
creating like you just said creating the
second story and creating the russian
effect that it took on and it became
it became two stories it became the
thing that gary wrote about and the
thing that people turned it into and he
never wrote that
that it was cia conspiracy to addict
people to drugs or to to do that and it
became that and all of the people
including even chris matthews you know
it's funny i did a q a with him a week
and a half ago
um he was reading from the cliff notes
and
gary then spent instead of following up
on the story
that he wrote he was defending it and um
and that's what it became it became what
people said it was but then it became
also the
depiction of journalism both the
hierarchy of journalism the washington
post and the new york times versus this
little newspaper
and even his own superiors backing off
from supporting him yeah
well they
they supported him for a while obviously
it's so hard you know
films like this it's you know they're
also there's a documentary version of it
and there's also a mini series version
of it to sort of pack it all in but you
know they supported him for for for a
time
until they had corporate pressure and it
just became too much
um the raliotic scene is representative
of the one i mean that is much more um
him and also the mike machine character
or amalgams of a few characters but
that leota scene no one ever really came
to him in his hotel room um it was a dea
agent that had information about cia
handlers and pilots and it was the one
but
when he got that bit was exactly where
it is in the movie where he did go in as
his last bit and they they did were
backpedaling at that point you know they
wrote the the letter and that letter you
can't even find in terms of it being
printed we were able to get copies of
things but we could not find that
are you now friends with cia agent cia
agents do you know that do they hang out
because they know you between uh
homeland and this and they have a great
interest in your work well the homeland
they love because it's like a huge
confection you know and she would have
been fired in the second episode if it
was real you know because she's bipolar
and she's crazy um
so i don't know
how i guess they're just ignoring it you
know i was just talking uh to someone
about how
how sorry not someone rosemary um about
one thing that the movie what gary
didn't write about is the cia within the
cia you had bill casey who was the
director at that time and then you had
all the other guys doing their other
things so it's a secret organization the
right hand doesn't know what the left
hand is doing
so
that was something that in terms of what
he got wrong like i think that was
something that he could have
gotten into and it's not that it's
taking blame off of them
but um
you know
i don't know if that was left out
intentionally i was just talking to
jonathan weiner in washington dc who the
sheen character is partly based on and
we were talking about that so i think
that's
interesting um
and it wasn't gary's idea to package the
story that way or to oversimplify it
either
the beautiful time that
the family had in the lake before
everything hit the fan where was that i
was that was georgia
yeah we shot outside um
of atlanta and also i thought what was
really interesting about that scene was
am i right in saying that this was the
first
sort of big breaking article on the
internet
that went viral like we're so used to
things going viral now but that was you
know they're clicking away and they're
like is it up is it up yet and i don't
think any journalists or any people had
the experience before then of having
their words
kind of go out there in such a rapid way
and not be able to
that he did have to defend it in a
really different kind of way yeah you're
right and it was it was gary's idea to
do that and he felt the story had a high
unbelievability factor so like where
silicon valley or san jose there's this
new technology
let's let's use the internet to
allow people into my notebooks you know
kind of thing and check the sources and
see
the court documents or
or
interviews with different people and and
his notes and things like that